[Music]
finally we also need to recognize the
world has changed since know since the
paternalistic companies of the 1950s I
remember when I first started at work I
I work for shell and they still had a
company dentist they they had a company
bar you know everything was provided by
the company and that's what it used to
be like and if you look our pension
system and our tax system it's still
designed around the idea of a
paternalistic employer I don't think
that's what the balance between employer
and individual should be I want people
to feel that they have power over their
own pensions over their own childcare
arrangements
I want them to feel that they own their
own future so I'd like to see pensions
owned by the person rather than the
company paid directly into the person's
pension account in the same way we now
do with childcare vouchers and I also
think that with the advent of fiber we
can see much more flexibility in terms
of the way people work well I hope we
can see more people working for multiple
employers being able to build up a
portfolio so they gave for their life I
mean I don't know if any of you have
read the book the hundred year life but
I'm certainly expecting to be working
for quite a long time we're all going to
have multiple employers say it's
important that we feel that we can own
our future security that we can own the
flexibility around our lives and we can
own that ability to shape our future I
think that's really important I think
the tax and benefits system has a lot to
catch up on
in terms of way people live their lives
because if you're anything like me
you'll find that there is endless
complexity in terms of things like
pension arrangements it's not simple
it's not transparent about what you do
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you